über 29 millionen menschen haben sich
bereits in deutschland mit dem corona
virus infiziert jeder zehnte entwickelt
langzeitfolgen man geht er davon aus und
ist es wieder vorbei aber es hat einfach
nicht aufgehört es ist einfach geblieben
longo bild geht quer durch die
gesellschaft
das sind menschen wie du und ich die
sind jung eigentlich arbeitsfähig
eigentlich leistungsfähig und können
einfach ihrem tagwerk nicht mehr
nachgehen
viele stehen mitten im leben wissen
nicht ob sie jemals wieder zu alter
stärke finden
natürlich hat man was zur unterrichtung
gespart aber das ist halt ja nun auch
nicht einen lebensentwurf der der der
den man haben möchte
das gesundheits- und sozialsystem
überfordert im ungünstigsten fall ist
dass
es nur zeitbombe die betroffenen oft
allein gelassen
also setzt einfach ein sozialer abstieg
durch diese
arbeitsunfähigkeit
[Musik]
ich war eine von diesen leuten die man
so werden sie die jede woche woanders
aufgelegt hat woanders moderiert hat ich
habe ständig irgendwas gedreht ich war
immer auf den events auf konzerten ganze
zeit
charlotte milan ist unter ihrem
künstlernamen dieser wie bekannt
freiberufliche moderatorin podcast dj
ein leben zwischen klubs events und
ihren eigenen youtube format
heute leidet die 35 jährige unter longo
wird als sie sich mit corona im herbst
letzten jahres infizierte war der
verlauf ungewöhnlich heftig und das
obwohl sie doppelt geimpft war
ich hatte zum beispiel die ganze zeit
ganz krasse durchblutung probleme meine
hände haben sich immer angeführt nämlich
so im kalten schnee fassen und ich hatte
von anfang an ganz ganz krass herzrasen
und eben auch extremes fieber ganz
schlimm schüttelfrost und alles hat
gebrannt also mein heil zum eine lunge
haben gebrannt und das auch noch möglich
monate danach das war unglaublich sind
einfach nicht aufgehört dazu entwickelte
sie eine diabetes typ 1 schleichen kam
neue symptome dazu wie geschmacksverlust
haarausfall wortfindungsstörungen
probleme mit der galle und
bauchspeicheldrüse
auch ihre private lebensplanung geriet
mit der infektion durcheinander
wir wollten eigentlich natürlich an
meine väter wochen flüge nach kuba wir
auf jeden fall auch hervor irgendwie
kinder bei zu kriegen und so aber das
ist jetzt erstmal alles aktuell nicht
denkbar so
also mein körper ist auf jeden fall
gerade nicht in der lage diese pläne so
umzusetzen jetzt gerade aktuell es
erstmal alles wieso eingefroren seitdem
nach heiligendamm com patienten die sich
von ihrer corona infektion nicht erholt
haben für viele andere die diagnose
longkou wird das ganze leben sagt
chefärztin jedes frommhold
das leben mit longo witt wird nicht so
sein wie vor der infektion die patienten
müssen wenn sie wirklich von
ausgeprägter fertig symptomatik also
erschöpfung betroffen sind oder wenn sie
ausgeprägte atemstörungen und belastungs
luftnot haben aber auch kognitive
einschränkungen lernen mit welchen
möglichkeiten nur mit welchen techniken
sie diese symptome gut bewerkstelligen
können
lange war es unvorstellbar dass er
wieder auf dienstreisen fährt jan fries
ist geschäftsführer eines unternehmens
in berlin von co wird ist er zwar
genesen aber noch nicht gesund
ja das ist so lange dauert ist halt da
muss man ganz klar sagen aber was soll
ich versuche ja mal dazu
rückblick im winter
2021 hatte sich anpries mit corona
infiziert er war wie die meisten damals
noch ungeimpft auf der intensivstation
kämpfte er um sein leben
und was hatte ich durch die zeit
getragen
familie glaube was man so hat und dann
naja ich hatte foto von meinen kindern
dabei
das soll festgehalten
eine einschneidende zeit sagt er seine
lunge wurde vom virus zu 80 prozent
zerstört
die er zusammen gesagt die sieht aus wie
bei jemandem der 20 jahre zwei
schachteln am tag geraucht hat und so
viele mir ich konnte
nach der entlassung aus dem krankenhaus
fünf meter gehen was das muss ich mich
hinsetzen und puten über ein jahr später
band check up für patienten wie anpries
ist schwierig einen termin an der posco
wird ambulanz wie hier an der
medizinischen hochschule hannover zu
bekommen seine lunge hat sich immer noch
nicht komplett von der kuh wird
infektion erholt und ihn quälen noch
weitere beschwerden
sie stärke verloren
kann hat massive schlafprobleme das ist
sache wo ich sage ich der christen im
vergleich zu den anderen symptomen
relativ gut weg was halt wichtig richtig
schwierig ist es halt dieses herz
kreislauf thema das ich ständig defekte
hatte
longo wird eindeutig zu diagnostizieren
soll immer noch schwierig sagt seine
behandelnde ärztin nora dreck
tatsache dass es ja unglaublich viele
verschiedene symptome über 200 symptome
in einer kurve der erkrankung dann gibt
macht es zusätzlich schwer da muss immer
das gesamtbild betrachten und bei den
einzelnen patienten schauen was steht im
vordergrund was ist eventuell auf die
gruppe der kranken zurückzuführen die
ambulanz ist völlig überlastet hat
zehnmal so viele anfragen wie es termine
gibt und deshalb versuchen wir schon im
telefongespräch
herauszufiltern wer es wirklich schwer
betroffen wo ist das wahrscheinlich dass
es ein anhalten des posthofs syndrom hat
die anderen müssen wir leider vertrösten
vor ihrer infektion hatte anja ein
aktives leben unternahm mit ihrer
tochter fahrer tun von münchen nach
venedig dreimal sport die woche war für
die 46-jährige normalen ihren job als
sonderschulpädagogen liebte sie und
bekam viel anerkennung und
das ist an das leben nach ihrer corona
infektion ihren vollen namen möchte sie
nicht nennen sie leidet an einer
besonders schweren form von longkou wird
dem chronischen fertig syndrom
gefangen im körper
aufstehen und sich an den tee machen das
fühlt sich für anja oft an wie
hochleistungssport inzwischen hat sie
pflegestufe eins bekommt hilfe im
haushalt und beim einkaufen
und das geld auf dem konto auch und ich
habe jetzt einfach
also ist jetzt einfach ein sozialer
abstieg durch diese
arbeitsunfähigkeit
karin wüst von der beratungsstelle für
berufskrankheiten beobachtet für viele
wird longo wird zum armutsrisiko
wenn sie unter longo witt leiden dann
gibt es 72 wochen krankengeld wenn diese
wochen um sind und sie sind immer noch
nicht gesund und sie haben keine
anerkennung als arbeitsunfall oder als
berufskrankheit dann ist der weg wenn
sie nicht das schaffen gesund zu werden
zum im harz 4 relativ schnell
anja ist sich sicher sie hat sich bei
der arbeit in der schule angesteckt
damals gab es noch keinen impfstoff
ihrer erkrankung will sie deshalb als
arbeitsunfall oder als berufskrankheit
anerkennen lassen das würde ihr eine
bessere finanzielle absicherung bringen
die anträge auf anerkennung einer
berufskrankheit haben seit corona enorm
zugenommen corona macht inzwischen mit
abstand den großteil aller
berufskrankheiten aus tendenz steigend
im toll von anja hat die gesetzliche
unfallversicherung sofort abgelehnt
bisher wird corona nur bei gesundheits-
und pflegepersonal als berufskrankheit
anerkannt als lehrerin sieg einem
erhöhten infektionsrisiko ausgesetzt
schreibt ihr die versicherung
da wo viele kinder sind da wo viele
menschen in geschlossenen räumen sind
die sich ungeschützt aufhalten ist für
mich überhaupt keine frage dass das zu
einer berufskrankheit jetzt zählen
sollte
verantwortlich für diese verordnung ist
das
bundesarbeitsministerium ein interview
lehnte der minister ab schriftlich
teilte sein ministerium mit zitat
die laufende und abgeschlossene
arbeitsmedizinische forschung konnte
bislang kein wesentlich erhöhtes
infektionsrisiko für tobit 19 bei
lehrerinnen und lehrern gegenüber der
allgemeinbevölkerung nachweisen
anja kämpft nun darum ihre erkrankung
als arbeitsunfall geltend zu machen doch
dafür müsste sie nachweisen bei welcher
person sie sich angesteckt hat
das ist fast das ist schier unmöglich
und aus datenschutzrechtlichen gründen
kriegen die versicherten auch gar nicht
gesagt
wer ob ein kollege oder ein schüler
innen oder oder kollegin infiziert war
an ihr soll die unfallversicherung
verklagen auch wenn das ein langer kampf
wird das ist für mich halt
furchtbar fühlt sich an wie eine strafe
für irgendwas was ich nicht weiß ich ich
hab halt meine gesundheit verloren ich
habe das leben was ich gelebt habe
komplett verloren ja und dieses kämpfen
in diesem zustand in dem ich bin tut mir
jetzt nicht gut mir einfach kraft die
ich eigentlich für die genesung brauche
zurück zu jan pries und seiner familie
kürzlich waren sie zusammen am meer
surfurlaub mit freunden und alles schien
wieder möglich
hat es genau anderthalb wochen gedauert
dieses positive gefühl zu behalten und
dann kamen die die infektion und seitdem
ist wieder alles auf anfang das corona
virus schlug zum zweiten mal zu obwohl
die anpries mittlerweile doppelt geimpft
ist er leidet unter infekten fieber und
muskelschmerzen
er ist jetzt wirklich wieder auf 1 0 zur
apple bike fahren ist nicht surfen ist
noch nicht so spazieren im besten falle
egal alle freizeitaktivitäten ob jetzt
irgendwie kultur im dorf in brinkum
mache ich allein mit den kids oma opa
helfen oder ins schwimmbad allein das
heißt ich mich körperlich
seit seiner corona infektion führt jan
pries ein kranken tagebuch
da sieht man halt das seit dem ersten
tag als im ersten februar letzten jahres
das ist heute ungefähr 40 prozent der
tage
mit irgendwelchen infekten so waren dass
ich mich körperlich einfach maximal
schonen musste also das ist ja fast die
hälfte also ich habe glaube ich an
infekten alles mitgenommen was was geht
man erklärt dass damit das immunsystem
durch diesen eingriff durch durch corona
massiv geschädigt ist und einfach jedes
kleine jede kleines virus jedes
bakterium mitnimmt mit sorge blickte auf
den herbst und winter eine dritte corona
infektion will er unbedingt vermeiden
doch nicht nur seine familie hat viele
kontakte auch als geschäftsführer ist er
oft auf dienstreisen trifft andere
menschen wenn man als risikopatient für
sich entscheidet dass das risiko von
kontakt für andere oder gegenüber
anderen zu groß ist dann wäre ich
einfach in dem sinne mit meinem
bisherigen job nicht mehr arbeitsfähig
das ist halt so dass das risiko für die
für die zukunft nicht natürlich über die
jahre hat man was zurückgelegten gespart
aber das ist halt ja nun auch nicht in
den lebensentwurf der der den den man
irgendwie haben möchte
durch lang wird nicht mehr voll
arbeitsfähig zu sein diese angst ist
immer da
professor joachim kugler ist
gesundheitsökonom und forscht zu den
wirtschaftlichen auswirkungen von
longkou wird auf das sozialsystem
im ungünstigsten fall ist aus einer
zeitbombe fall natürlich viele
lebensplanungen gehen ja davon aus dass
man kontinuierlich berufstätig sein wird
aber wenn longo vip ostkurve das nicht
möglich macht dann
ist das natürlich für den betroffenen
will an schwierige situation mehr über
das krankheitsbild longo wird erfahren
dass will die münchner initiative help
for future vis á vis hat sich
entschlossen zu unterstützen hat ihre
krankengeschichte öffentlich gemacht
über instagram will sie über lankowitz
aufklären
schreiben nur wenn betroffene will trägt
so viele fragen jetzt denke also dass
man schon so verzweifelt dass man eben
denkt ich bin jetzt
die gründerin haben eine digitale
plattform entwickelt longo wird
patienten können dort angaben zur krone
infektion und ihrem krankheitsverlauf
machen die gesammelten daten sind anonym
deswegen haben wir einen fragebogen
entwickelt der sich eben nicht nur mit
der korona infektion selbst
auseinandersetzt sondern erstmalig alle
symptome erheben und dann eben auch
sehen zu können anhand der
anonymisierten daten gibt es
korrelationen gibt es parallelen zum
beispiel zu einer speziellen
vorerkrankung die dann eben auch zu
einer schwereren longo wird erkrankung
führt in dem interdisziplinären
forschungsteam ist auch hausarzt andreas
durstewitz er überprüft die antworten im
fragebogen nimmt kontakt zu den
patienten auf ehrenamtlich denn auch er
will mehr über longo wird wissen
man kann hier ja clustern altersgruppen
sehen geschlechter sehen man kann als
das alter sehen vor erkrankung erkennen
sodass man
statistisch am ende und auch wenn man
das wissenschaftlich untersucht
tatsächlich beschwerdebilder symptom
konstellationen syndrome sehen kann und
viel schneller zur diagnose kommt die
gründerinnen arbeiten an einer lankowitz
studie gemeinsam mit der universität
münchen die epidemiologin und bio
statistikerin ursula berger fordert
deutlich mehr finanzieller unterstützung
von der politik es gebe zu wenig
forschung über die krankheit
es geht auch darum dass wir jetzt für
den herbst und den winter 2022
abschätzen müssen welche maßnahmen
wollen wir treffen um neue infektionen
zu vermeiden da müssen wir abschätzen
was kostet eine neuinfektion wäre es was
kosten uns die maßnahmen und des alles
abzuschätzen ist relativ komplex und
dafür brauchen wir viele und vor allem
aktuelle daten auch weil deutschland wie
in den jahren zuvor um die frage ringen
wird welche massnahmen braucht es zur
pandemie an dem charlotte milan alias
vis á vis beunruhigt der laxe umgang mit
corona infektionen
diese vorstellung dass es noch mal
passieren könnte ist auf jeden fall für
mich unerträglich also davor habe ich
wirklich todesangst ich bin halt jetzt
auf mehreren ebenen vor erkrankt und
möchte mir nicht ausmalen was passieren
würde wenn ich mich noch anstecken
davor habe ich unendlich 1 fahre ich
jeden tag jeden tag alles auf mich
wieder anzustellen
und antworten der politik stehen noch
aus wie betroffene vor dem sozialen
abstieg bewahrt werden können du leidest
unter lankowitz und willst deine
erfahrungen teilen dann schreibt uns in
die kommentare